Secretary of State Rex Tillerson is on
his way to Moscow for his first
high-level talks in Russia Tillerson
left Pisa Italy this morning after
meeting with other foreign ministers
they are considering how to move Russia
away from supporting Syria's ruling
regime Margaret Brennan is in Moscow
where the recent u.s. missile attack on
Syria will certainly be part of the
conversation Margaret good morning good
morning while secretary Tillerson said
world leaders all agree that the reign
of the Assad family is swiftly coming to
an end but leaders here in Moscow
disagree it is unclear whether Russia
failed to take this obligation seriously
or Russia has been incompetent but this
distinction doesn't much matter to the
dead hours ahead of his trip to Moscow
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
criticized Russia for propping up Syrian
dictator Bashar al-assad
Russia has really aligned itself with
the Assad regime the Iranians and
Hezbollah is that a is that a long-term
alliance that serves Russia's interest
this week the White House signaled that
President Trump may take further
military action the answer is is that if
you gas a baby if you put a barrel bomb
in two innocent people I think you can
an at you will you will see a response
from this president the Kremlin
condemned the u.s. attack and said it
damaged already fragile US relations a
blow to president Trump's campaign
promise to improve them you know when
you think about it wouldn't it be nice
if we actually did get along with Russia
the change in rhetoric is striking
Tillerson will urge Russia to stop
propping up Assad prevent further use of
chemical weapons and raised concerns
about election meddling a former oil
executive Rex Tillerson has extensive
experience in Russia President Vladimir
Putin once awarded him the order of
friendship but now that he's America's
top diplomat that only goes so far the
u.s. strikes may complicate achieving
any of his goals Russian international
affairs council director andrey korsunov
has become when you were more difficult
for trump but it is now even more
for Putin as well because you know he
has to show that he's a strong leader
and that he will not yield under the US
pressure and just to give you a sense of
the anticipation around secretary Taylor
since meetings it's on all the main
papers and take a look at the cover of
this leading political magazine it says
it all Trump and Putin go head to head
over Syria
Charlie Margaret Brennan in Moscow
thanks Margaret